you and your lovely wife Nia have a
one-year-old son daughter one-year-old
daughter no it's alright it's alright
it's alright what are you supposed to
memorize what everybody has now I have
one guy whose job it is to tell me if
it's a son or a daughter needs a son I
thought we were friends yeah Wow
yeah anyway not that I really rely on
these things but it's just no you have a
one-year-old daughter yes I'm just
curious what's it I said take two okay
take two I don't know we're gonna keep
all that in I want people at home to
know just how shitty things are what so
what's what's the best thing so far in
your opinion about being a being a dad
ah I actually like going to the park
with my daughter pushing her on the
swing you know all that and then also at
her first birthday party I realize how
lucky I was to have a girl because they
just sort of chill out and take things
in and I saw the little boys they're
like maniacs
they're like throwing stuff ripping like
literally watching my daughter she just
kind of waves hi at everybody and the
boys would come up just rip toys out of
her hands it was like breaking my heart
because she's she's you know she's so
innocent she hasn't met an [ __ ] yet
so like it's sort of like this Oh what
was that vibe and then the boys you know
that Klieman are they throwing rocks
down on the car it was like Braveheart
every time I told him it's like you guys
you got to stop doing this and then also
you can't you can't tell other people's
kids not to do stuff right so you got to
kind of like be loudly like hey he's
climbing up on the utility pole and kind
of hope that somebody does something
we're back in the day you could yell at
people's kids and I think that that
needs to come back and that's what's
holding back this country
so at some point you gotta be take it
off hey I said don't do that and then
you got to be like hey look you little
[ __ ] you know that's my car
yeah I'm throwing rocks on it yeah yeah
before I throw you over the wall you're
not gonna do it but you scare them a
little as a dad do you feel that you
have more or less importance than you
used to have when you were just a couple
of no children way less weight less yes
that's been my experience as well yeah
like when you're dating just you feel
like you're number one then the second
you get like engaged you become the
backup quarterback like you start going
down the depth chart and once you have a
kid I think I'm like fifth now like it
goes my daughter then my wife my
mother-in-law like the UPS driver I
don't mind because I'm like anti-social
always you know like I had the best
Christmas I've ever had since you know I
was a little kid and believed in Santa
Claus just coming back with a kid is
then you don't have to really engage
with adults anymore which is awesome you
just come in and like hey Billy you like
hey here she is
oh my god they all grabbed a - no but
you can go hit the bar hang out nobody's
talking to you it's tremendous hit the
bar in your house yeah yeah yeah I don't
go out like some Angela's Ashes stuff I
just go over and I have a couple of pops
yeah yeah you do what's right that's
right get behind the wheel you know let
me ask you something ask you something
now I gotta move away again it's just so
easy to offend people now you have to do
it